heather and i
many times have
discussed
the fact that modernity
has taken many essential human functions
and it has
shifted them to the market
right whereas a person 200 or 300 years
ago
would have had many close contacts they
probably would have known many of them
for their whole life
they would have had a life partner
they would have produced children almost
automatically those relationships would
have been very important to them all of
those things would be true
now children are very optional partners
are increasingly
optional and as the pandemic set in
it dawned on us
that
people trapped without even a single
person that they could look in the eye
and say
is this making sense to you because i
hear everybody saying nonsense and i
don't know what to make of it if you
didn't have
one person that you could trust
to say yeah i see it too
you were in grave danger of not making
any sense at all
and
i wonder if that's part of what happened
is that lots of people
who didn't have partners because you
don't absolutely need one
got
isolated in a way that maybe is almost
without precedent
of course it is it is all like
uh
stalin isolated his population because
he knew that they were much more
vulnerable for propaganda than he
intentionally did isolate his population
because he knew that they were
it was much easier to
to use propaganda in that case
hitler didn't but but the the the effect
was it was was the same actually as mass
formation exists it all it also
spontaneously creates isolation and and
a certain loneliness but here in this
case with the corona crisis we have
never seen such an extreme state of
isolation of the population never i
think
and at the same time people were
constantly
bombarded with these messages
with propaganda through their iphones
through their television through radio
constantly so it was the most extreme
example
of of of an optimal situation to use
propaganda
so a couple things i want to make sure
we we highlight here
one
is
your point
about
one mass formation often follows another
i was going to ask you about this
because
what i've seen
and i almost wonder if there's not
an addiction
where because people feel isolated and i
will argue in a moment that that is
the most
because our ancestors were starving and
because no human is equipped to to
survive alone in the world
being isolated is a terrifying
experience because it's basically a
precursor to starving to death
[Music]
so when people feel that isolation
either because it's induced by somebody
who wants to control them or because
it's a natural consequence of
technologies and economic systems that
separate us
they have this
desire
to replace something that they've lost
they don't necessarily know what it is
but when it is offered
in the form of
sign up for this narrative and you
suddenly become part of this large
enthusiastic group right we're going to
be the winners we're going to end up
with the food and all you got to do is
believe these things and say them and
punish the right people and you can be
one of us right that satisfies
it relieves the pressure of the threat
right
and then the point is at some point
coronavirus stops being a compelling
narrative or the
slate of beliefs is so
far off the evidence and podcasts are so
full of people talking about you know
the hazards that you may have exposed
yourself to if you believe these things
that
people don't they're not enthusiastic
about it anymore and so then the point
is well
they're still looking for something that
causes them to feel safe and together
with people and so they're they're
primed for some other topic
and i you know i almost i
i watched
um
trump
as this uniting force right we have to
do away with this demon
become
the
public health narrative right they're
obviously
almost unrelated topics
and yet people went seamlessly from one
to the other because it was they were on
the same team and they had become
addicted to that team
and
um
you know i i do wonder where we are now
uh obviously yes
it was also remarkable i think that as
soon as the corona narrative disappeared
a little bit in the background uh we we
the ukraine the the
ukraine seemed to fulfill a little bit
the same function there was again this
tendency to consider the good and the
bad very much in black and white and
then also there was like a new object of
anxiety and a new
uh intolerance for dissonant voices uh
also this new enthusiasm this new
solidarity um yes
i also think that at the moment now
it seems that
mass formation became a little bit
milder mitigated a little bit but i
don't think we are
so we see that the consequences of the
of the mass formation are very very
severe at the psychological level like i
don't know how it is in the united
states but i think it is the same but
now that students are allowed to come
back to university to follow courses on
campus they don't show up anymore only
five percent shows up
the same holes for the professors and
the assistants at university the
buildings are empty uh in companies i
hear the same story and
uh the the the cultural sector the
theaters and the movies nobody shows up
so that shows us something very specific
namely that the mass formation was
extremely destructive at the level of
the social bond
and
that you know a social bond
people always at the same time
find their deepest satisfaction in the
social bond but they also have to
overcome a certain resistance
to take a step to the other because of
all kinds of things shame anxiety
uncertainty self-awareness and so on and
so if
if the energetic
the psychological energy invested in the
social bond goes below is a certain
threshold then you typically see that
people prefer to stay home and that's
what they do now that's what they do now
many people stay home or many people
don't go back to work don't go back to
university
and this probably will prepare them for
an even more more intense example of
mass formation in the nearby future
unless
again and that's so important the
dissonant voices really do their best
continue to speak out and that's that's
i i'm confident that
there is a group of people who is very
determined now that they won't
remain silent and that they will speak
out so i'm also i'm confident that in
the years to come probably will be will
be very difficult years
but the group who uh
defies the masses and and refuses to buy
into the mainstream narrative will be
large and and determined enough i think
to keep open a certain path no matter
how difficult it is
so that a totalitarian system cannot
destroy everything
well we have to figure out how to retain
our ability to speak
to the world i think the the people who
have emerged globally it's a very
powerful
group of people and i think we you know
we are we are well positioned to speak
um
to speak carefully about what's
unfolding and i agree that what is what
is to come may be well worse than what
we've already
um seen
[Music]
you